amy is starting off this hour in
Michigan Hayami
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi dude
thank you so much for taking my call um
you don't know me but I feel like I know
you first I want to say thank you for
changing my entire life financially I'm
debt free almost debt-free because of
you and I've told you many times for
advice so you feel like part of the
family I'm mentioning your name every
other day like there's smoke those days
of that so I need to advise about my
current situation which is a little bit
dire I have a lot of expenses and I
don't know how to pay for them without
taking out a loan be it a credit card
well I don't really like credit cards
but like I was thinking of taking out a
home equity loan or something because I
just literally have no money to my name
and I need to pay the mortgage and pay
for milk and food and things like that
and I just have no money I make too much
money to be qualifying for like Amy and
things like that so I get no aid no help
from anyone and I have no money to my
name so I'm living paycheck to paycheck
and not really able to afford things
even doing that because I have so many
different bills not necessarily debt but
like just different bills to pay like
for the house the car the insurance and
all that stuff so what do you think what
do you make what do you make a year I
made almost 80 okay so why are you this
broke I am a single mom and I do not get
any kind of support you make $1,000 a
year I know but I'm a single mom and I
pay for child care for two children so
one
lots of people make $80,000 a year with
two kids and they're not even close to
broke yeah well they have most people
have child support no they don't
I'm talking about a couple married with
two children that the one person works
and makes eighty thousand or two of them
work and they make eighty thousand they
don't have any trouble paying their
bills yeah
you got the single mom thing I'll twist
it up here so what do you do for a
living I am a writer okay
and you net your taxable income is
$80,000 a year
that's like 77 my do you work well you
work for someone writing correct okay
all right cool so how much is your house
payment my house payment is 815 how much
is your car payment I don't have a car
payment good how much are your credit
card payments I don't have any credit
cards how much are your student loan
payments I don't don't have student
loans okay you have an $800 house
payment you make $80,000 a year and you
have to feed two kids three three I have
child care for two of the three okay
been fairly normal for most people that
are working okay and what do you pay for
child care
I play 350 a week for child care and
dollars a month so $2,000 a month goes
to your house payment and your child
care yes
that oughta leave a lot of money for
milk well but I just have so many other
things like I have my homeowner's
insurance my conscience my you know just
different utilities groceries I just
literally have like five dollars to my
name right now and then you are so
freakin disorganized it's unbelievable
really and your budget doesn't exist
because I'm sitting here looking at I'm
sitting here looking at six thousand
dollars a month coming in to your house
and I spent 2,000 of it a while ago and
so far you can't pay for with four
thousand dollars some lights so I know I
don't have six thousand a month so I I
have a thousand dollars a week that I
got well ten eighty seven a week that I
make okay that's four thousand dollars a
month that's forty eight thousand
dollars
here that is not 77,000 - taxes unless
you're getting a $15,000 tax refund no I
bet I make 77 well I get a bonus that 77
includes my bonus
how much is remaining - whites what
how much is your bonus it's a 10% bonus
I'm 7,000 of it's a bonus this does not
describe where the money is going how
big was your tax refund last year I
didn't get why that refund um I didn't
get any money from the sides I don't
think I got if I got some it was very
negligible okay maybe like $500 okay so
here's the thing just gonna put a little
money in here just to make sure I'm
doing this right got sixty four thousand
dollars a year and make sure I'm doing
this exactly right yeah your take-home
pay are you putting money in your 401 K
yes I am oh okay
and how much I'm I'm maxing out the the
company contribution I think it's like
12% is the company contribution so I'm
just putting in 12% do you have any more
I think it's like 100 per pay period per
week okay that would be 400 so I'm still
I've still got you should be getting
home with you're getting home with about
$4,000 a month and you should be getting
home not counting your 401 K with about
fifty five hundred a month not now
that's not counting your bonus but still
okay so here's what we've got to do I'll
just back up and I'm trying to run your
budget out of here on the air because
it's just not making sense
okay so what part of Michigan are you in
Grand Rapids Oh perfect okay here's what
I'm gonna put you des run with a how old
are you I am 43 okay I'm gonna put you
on hold and Kelly's gonna set you up
with one of our financial coaches as my
as my gift as my gift and they're gonna
sit down with you and help you
to do a budget and put this together
there's no reason you should be this
broke there's no reason you should be
this broke there is no reason you should
be this broke you have got to just do
the simple math on this every dollar has
a name plan out where the money's going
and lay it all out I don't know where
you're putting this money but before you
start talking about borrowing money to
buy milk which is how you started the
conversation because life's just too
hard as a single mom before I learned
you made seventy seven thousand dollars
a year you would stop your 401k
contributions before you you don't
borrow money to buy milk because your
401k is funded now I don't think that's
necessary but these are the kinds of
choices that you're not making
consciously you're like spin-spin-spin
then you run out of money I got $5.00 to
my name and I'm panicked and it's all
because I'm a single mom and that's just
simply not true it's because you're
disorganized and you don't have a good
budget so we'll help you with that I'm
gonna help you get it your budget going
go ahead and put her in Financial Peace
University - lets get her go through the
class and did some people around her to
go with the coaching and let's help her
get this straightened out